Please welcome somebody,
a couple I'm so excited to talk to.
From "The People's Court",
Judge Marilyn Milian and John Schlesinger.
(audience cheering)
Hello!
Thank you for having us.
We're so excited to be here.
Great to be here, thanks Drew.
I've been so excited to speak with you.
First of all, I mean, I'm totally single.
I have two daughters, so I have so much love in my life.
My cup runneth over in fact.
Anytime I have a minute I'm like, can I just be alone?
So believe me, when I say I'm single, it's not a boo-hoo,
it's an absolute empowered choice.
And, that said, I always had like a fantasy that if I,
you know, if I was to be with someone,
in the past or in the future,
my total fantasy is to collaborate with them.
And I just think there's something so darn groovy
about being able to have that and collaborate.
Every waking minute together, together!
It's so funny, yeah, it's so funny.
This was kind of a logical progression though,
because when I was a judge and she was taping
in New York sometimes, or in Connecticut,
I had difficult issues that would come up.
I'd call her from chambers and say, hey,
I've got this, this and this, what do you think?
And I'd bounce it off her.
And then, other days, I'd get the phone call
when I'm in chambers, in my court, outside of my courtroom.
And it's her in Connecticut or in New York,
calling and saying, I've got this situation,
what do you think?
Yeah.
And before we were judges, we were both prosecutors.
I was a state prosecutor and he was a federal prosecutor.
So we would...
We had the same kind of exchange.
When we were wooing each other we would go to
each other's trials and give each other tips and stuff.
So being in the same business is a lot of fun.
But now we are literally, literally inseparable.
Yeah, I mean we never imagined that this was gonna happen.
In a million years.
I never imagined
that it would look like this, where our home life
and our work life is all blended together.
There's no respite, no hiding.
No hiding, the studio's in our living room.
This is where we put our Christmas tree.
Now I've gotta put my Christmas tree
on my head in the kitchen basically.
And I've seen you on other interviews.
And although you say that you're together all the time
you always seem to be laughing about it.
No, it's great, it's magical.
(Marilyn laughing)
You have like a really nice lightness.
No, it's a good thing I like my husband.
Like we always say it, isn't it great
that we actually like each other,
because this could really bomb if we didn't.
We have different personalities,
and that's actually worked to strengthen the relationship.
Because she is a total type triple A,
you know, on top of every detail.
I'm a type B who's not quite the same way.
It's funny, I tell people if we were two animals,
she's like a shark, she never stops moving.
It's just on, on, on everywhere, on to the next task.
She's gonna die if she stops moving.
Me, I'm like a manatee.
I just kind of bump around and nibble on the grass here,
nibble on the grass there.
And you know, they get along really well,
sharks and manatees, who knew?
It's funny because you mentioned the type A, type B.
I wanted to talk to you guys
because I am a type B executer with type A expectations.
Oh wow.
Whoa.
And I have a real issue with time management.
I've worked on it.
And I thought, you know what?
I'm gonna lay down some accountability in my life
that I just simply cannot mess with.
'Cause I was always five, 10, 15, 20 minutes late.
Because you could be.
But this has been my ongoing, you know,
sort of addiction if you will.
A habit that I've wanted to break,
a cycle I've wanted to break.
And we're gonna go to commercial break really quickly,
but when we come back, I was wondering
with your type A and type B, 'cause I relate to both of you,
if you guys can give me some tips on time management.
Because I know that, well, we'll,
I know so much about your process
'cause I've studied it, with your alarm clocks,
and your things, and your blabbity blahs.
But I wanna learn.
(upbeat music)